[Música]
Bienvenidos a este programa especial de
ciencia y tecnología aquí en Francia 24
soy Valentina Torres Sánchez y es un
gusto acompañarlos de nuevo esta misión
está dedicada a hacer un recuento de los
principales hitos de la carrera espacial
hasta repasar los hechos que durante
2022 sin duda le han devuelto el interés
al espacio en una nueva era de
exploración pero volvamos en la historia
el primer granito de la carrera espacial
lo dio la unión soviética el medio de la
Guerra Fría los satélites eran
herramientas clave de espionaje al
tiempo que demostraban la capacidad
científica y la potencia militar de las
Naciones el sputnik 1 fue el primer
satélite puesto en órbita
en el sputnik 2 La Unión soviética envió
al espacio al primer ser vivo la perrita
laica el plan siempre contempló la
muerte del animal
ocho meses después el presidente
estadounidense
firmó el decreto que estipulaba la
creación de la Administración Nacional
de aeronáutica y el espacio la NASA
pero la unión soviética seguía liderando
en 1961 Yuri gargarín se convirtió en el
primer hombre en orbitar la tierra y
volver a salvo
una hazaña igualada 23 días después por
el estadounidense Alan
[Música]
pero fue el bloque soviético el que
llevó a la primera mujer al espacio con
Valentina tereshkova lanzó la primera
nave multiplaza y protagonizó la primera
caminata espacial
Pero la fecha que marcó la historia y
las conciencias fue el 20 de julio de
1969 cuando Neil Armstrong y se
convirtieron en los primeros hombres en
pisar la luna
desde 1981 y hasta 2011 la NASA mantuvo
su programa de transbordadores
naves reutilizables como el Columbia el
Challenger el Discovery el Atlantis y el
endeble
los soviéticos pusieron en órbita lamir
la primera estación espacial de
investigación que estuvo habitada y
marcó la culminación del programa
espacial de la unión soviética durante
13 años permitió importantes
colaboraciones internacionales y albergó
tanto a como nautas como astronautas
[Música]
más de una década después la NASA logró
posar sobre la superficie marciana el
primer robot explorador el sojuna
fue hasta 1998 cuando en una cooperación
con Rusia la agencia espacial roscosmos
envió el primer módulo
ese mismo año Washington envió el Unity
a estos se fueron aco otros módulos
entre ellos el Columbus de la agencia
espacial Europea y el kivo de la agencia
japonesa en años siguientes
desde entonces son múltiples los logros
que se han conseguido justamente
hablando sobre la estación espacial
internacional conversamos con Claudio
Martínez astrónomo e investigador de la
fundación azar en Argentina y esto nos
dijo
Bueno uno de los más importantes hitos
de la carrera espacial con respecto a la
estación espacial internacional es
fundamentalmente el adaptarse al espacio
algo que parece Tan sencillo algo que
parece tan tonto si querés pero que
implica mucho porque toda la preparación
psicológica la preparación de vida estar
sin una gravedad que se sienta estar
flotando ver cómo tu cuerpo se desadapta
estar lejos de tu familia es todo muy
complicado desde lo psicológico entonces
todas esas experiencias han hecho que
hoy en día por ejemplo se pueda pensar
en un viaje muy largo también
consultamos con Germán puerta integrante
de la asociación de astronomía de
Colombia cuál podría ser considerada la
mayor hazaña en años posteriores y esto
fue lo que nos dijo realmente la NASA ha
tenido
extraordinarios desarrollos
Yo diría que sin embargo
los más extraordinarios fueron los
Robert
en Marte
no solamente porque
nos dieron una información impresionante
sobre el planeta rojo confirmando lo que
se sospechaba que fue un plan que tuvo
agua y océanos hace varios millones de
años por lo tanto las posibilidades de
que haya hubiera existido alguna forma
de vida son muy altas Pese a que la NASA
la agencia espacial Europea y otros
exploradores históricos y recientes del
espacio se dedicaron a cooperar en
investigación y desarrollo y también a
trabajar por su cuenta para conseguir
nuevas hazañas como es el caso de China
el panorama del programa espacial
soviético heredado por Rusia pronto fue
decayendo
realmente ha tenido
muy mala fortuna en ciertos programas
por ejemplo en el en el tema de marte
desde los años 60 Rusia ha lanzado
misiones A Marte también las Ha lanzado
en este en este siglo y todas han sido
un hombre verdadero fracaso
no han podido resolver muchos de los
problemas de comunicación de inclusive
de la fase más compleja que es hacer
descenso tiene el problema un problema
económico todo lo que hacía las
exploraciones espacial es extremadamente
caro cualquier misión cualquier cosa que
quieras poner en órbita estamos hablando
de quinientos millones de dólares para
arriba cualquier cosa aún lo más
sencillo Rusia mantuvo su capacidad de
lanzamiento de hecho hasta hace muy poco
Estados Unidos dependió de las naves
sabios para enviar carga y Humanos a la
estación eso cambió con la llegada de
escena de actores privados que cada vez
desarrollan más autonomía sus programas
hablamos de spacex que ya trabaja en
conjunto con la NASA y con cuyos cohetes
los falcon envía misiones al espacio
pero también de otras empresas que
quieren y que ya han llevado civiles al
espacio hablamos de Virgin y de Blue
origins es el conocido y emocionante
turismo espacial preguntamos a los
expertos si es un ámbito que puede
consolidarse a corto plazo
Todavía es muy caro pero sí en los
próximos diez años yo estimo van a ser
unos costos relativamente razonables
para que una persona común pueda ser un
viaje por el estilo de hecho se está
planificando hasta un hotel espacial
para el año dos antes del año 2030 me
parece un poco rápido y hay una cierta
competencia entre ellos no entre estos
multimillonarios
como besos bosque y otros y branson y
Todos quieren ser los primeros y
destacados Y eso está bien es una
competencia muy sana que nos va a
permitir grandes logros sin duda sin
duda 2022 fue un año de grandes hazañas
en el espacio la primera de la que
podemos hablar es de los resultados que
envió el súper telescopio James webb un
instrumento que no ha dejado de
sorprender con las imágenes que ha
logrado pero al hablar del James webb es
imposible dejar de lado a su predecesor
el
en realidad el universo antes
un universo ahí con sus galaxias y
nebulosas pero el juego nos cambió por
completo la visión no solamente en
ciencia
sino en el imaginario en la en la en el
colorido ahora el Jane está haciendo una
Revolución similar tanto en ciencia como
en el imaginario social y popular el
primero tiene un diámetro mayor que el
favor y el tenía dos metros y medio de
Espejo este ya casi siete metros y
además trabaja con la tecnología
infrarroja que permite detectar los
cuerpos que no puede ver el hubble en el
visual y algo que para muchos parecía
ciencia ficción ocurrió este año
hablamos de la misión Dart en un sistema
de dos asteroides en el que uno pequeño
llamado dimorfos giraba alrededor de
otro de mayor tamaño llamado dividimos
por primera vez con el impacto de una
nave se logró desviar la trayectoria del
cuerpo menor algo que serviría en un
futuro para proteger a la tierra de
grandes impactos
en realidad desde hace unos treinta años
está muy popularmente divulgado que la
posibilidad de los míos los objetos muy
cercanos a la tierra puedan impactar ya
pasó hasta sesenta y cinco millones de
años y fue el Exterminio de los
dinosaurios por un asteroide de diez
kilómetros en 1908 cayó en tungusca en
Rusia una piedrita podríamos compararla
de 30 a 40 metros e hizo un desastre si
hubiera caído sobre una ciudad le
hubiera destrozado Entonces está el
peligro latente sabemos que existe y
ahora tenemos la capacidad para empezar
a hacer tecnológicamente cambios o sea
desviar asteroides es una una
experiencia de hecho el cambio que se
pensaba hacer en la órbita de vivimos
era de apenas unas horas capaz que media
hora determinaron siendo casi 20 horas
de diferencia Y si seguimos en orden no
podemos dejar de lado el programa
artemis de volver a los humanos a la
luna pero no solo para explorar el
satélite sino para quedarse y establecer
una base intermedia Para futuras
misiones A Marte en la primera Fue
totalmente automática que salió perfecta
no hubo ninguna falla en todos los
veinticinco días de hecho inclusive es
una misión extremadamente larga porque
25 días Es realmente mucho Comparado
inclusive con las
artemisdos ya va a ser una misión
tripulada y artemis tren Ya piensa ser
descensos si uno dos y la tres que
realmente haya un descenso y astronautas
en la luna a partir de ahí va a ser la
parte de mandar impresoras 3D gigantes a
la luna para empezar a construir domos
para empezar a construir va una base
lunar real Por qué Porque la idea es que
en un futuro no demasiado lejano hacer
el viaje al planeta Marte Y eso implica
superior enormemente superior a la luna
entonces Si no dominamos primero el
viaje a la luna imposible pensar en un
viaje tan complejo como el planeta más
como lo decían los expertos Hay nuevas
potencias que han consolidado su
presencia en el espacio no podríamos
dejar pasar a China cuyo programa
espacial cumplió 30 años y consiguió
todas las metas propuestas tal es el
caso de la estación espacial tiangong
cuya estructura ya está completa no hay
duda que tienen
un que es una nación muy agresiva en el
cosmos
porque no solamente ha colocado su nueva
estación espacial ya han tenido otra su
Palacio celestial
la tiango uno
sino que colocaron algo que nadie había
hecho antes un Rover en La Cara Oculta
de la luna
y además un Rover en Marte el show o
Dios del fuego
y es la primera nación que logra en su
primer intento de descenso del martes
tiene éxito
Así es que tenemos una nación que tiene
grandes capacidades
sin duda algo que caracteriza
originalmente a la carrera por el
espacio entre Estados Unidos y la unión
soviética durante la Guerra Fría fue la
necesidad de demostrar el poderío de las
Naciones con el tiempo la cooperación
empezó a ganarle a la competencia hasta
que incluso llegó a perderse el interés
por el espacio luego de que enviar
humanos fuera de la tierra se
convirtiera en algo rutinario no
obstante están haciendo una nueva era en
la exploración del espacio la
participación de China India emiratos
árabes Unidos o Japón con programas
espaciales que avanzan velozmente y la
presencia de los actores privados sin
duda será la marca de esta nueva etapa
que pese a los costos dejan evidencia la
necesidad humana de explorar todo lo que
le es desconocido ya veremos que nos
trae esta aventura en los próximos años
así finalizamos este espacio a ustedes
Muchas gracias Gracias por acompañarnos
continúen con nosotros en France 24 y
France 24 punto com